the
You
Hope oh, I didn't realize my mic was on. Hi
Hello, hello, does someone explain to me why I
Have a diet I have a can of diet coke here
Why is it fizzing?
Like it like for some reason I put a metal straw in here earlier and it's fizzing like crazy and then I put I
put a paper straw in here and
It fizzes like crazy too
But when I take the straws out it stops fizzing
No, but every time I take the straw out it stops fizzing. It's the straw
See it's starting to fizz again after I put the straw back in
It's only the straw that's making it fizz I
Don't understand no I'm using a paper straw now
See I know you can't see but oops hold on I have to delete the text. I know you can't see but like
Paper straws are nasty. Well, it was fizzing crazy more with the metal straw. At least it's not fizzing as much with the paper straw
The straws have a lot of nucleation points
Nucleation points
Okay, well, it's not bad for me, right?
It's a sign that there's poison in the can no
We need our smartest pin pals on this. Yeah, it only fizzes when I have the straw in
I'm eating
Provolone cheese with them. I
Don't know some random salami. I don't think I like provolone cheese. I
Kind of taste like cheese farts
You know what I mean
And it's so thick like why is it so thick
It's the one I got was too thick it's too thick for my sandwiches on let me give some to the rats
So that way it's nice thick on my sandwich
One second, I'm just gonna give a bunch of cheese to the rats
I
So cute they're all fighting for the cheese I
Gave them all I gave them each like a piece of cheese, but they're all fighting each other for each other's cheeses
Maybe someone farted on that particular piece. No
Carbon dioxide forming bubbles on the micro holes in the surface of the straw
Hmm, okay
This sounds very scientific, I didn't know
Oh
There goes my tracking
The usual
Um
The usual stream scuff of course
Reckoning me
Cute glasses, thank you
Thank you, I like them a lot. I wear this outfit every time I play lizards 101
Wait, that's the wrong thing
There we go, there's my face again
You like seeing me in her natural habitat of scuff do the other girls have scuff
Be honest, am I the only scuff one be honest?
What where's my tracking go again, what the fuck I
Didn't do nothing this time
Oh
My god
So the phone I'm using still has like all of the
There you go, it still has all of this stuff on
iTunes that I bought like when I was fucking like 12
And
Is this a music video it's a music video I bought songs with music videos
It's the capitalist capitalism final boss. I was buying songs with their music videos
And I'm looking at it. I
Guess I was a fan of talking Angela
Yeah, I was buying them for like $1.99 each isn't that crazy I guess I was a fan of talking Angela. What is this?
Your computer is not authorized you must authorize this computer from the account menu before you can download previous purchases
Man, I want to see the talking Angela music video. It's called that's falling in love from talking Angela
Account menu
Account
Authorizations authorizes this computer. I have to put in my
Authorize
Oh my god
Is it gonna work do you want to watch a talking Angela music video with me?
Okay, I can't show you well they get flagged
We get flagged this is from so long ago. Oh
My god, it's her falling in love with talking Tom
I wouldn't risk it copyright strike incoming
That's it's such bad quality to why is it so blurry?
That's cute though. I just don't download it
Talking Angela music video
YouTube copyright system is very janky and broken. Don't risk it. Okay. I
Don't yeah, I thought I was the I was the bitch that bought music. Yep
Individual songs, that's how they that's how they scammed us back in the day
Got a little lady Gaga song
And you mute the song part and just tell us what the song is playing
But even the music video might get copyrighted, right?
Well as a shame
Now it's the artists getting scammed really
What's how oh
You can do it watch a long style, but what if you can't find it
What if you can't is it on YouTube it might be on YouTube do you want to watch talking?
Let me see you on talking Angela
Video teaser
There's no full music video here, it's not on YouTube
You cannot find the whole song on YouTube
Oh wait full video song HD
Wait, it's only a minute long
Is my version longer than a minute?
music videos
Do do do do do my version is two minutes and 30 seconds
Do I have like lost media here?
Do I have like
No, I can't post a link because I can't find the full song
Like the full music video
I
Got some valuable shit, huh? I have the Espanol version. Is this the full version?
Yeah, I'm not gonna watch the talking Angela as long as you sorry
The sacred text
Oh
Right
You know what we can watch along let me show you let me show you
I made a new song cover
20 seconds long, but it's fun
You can't hear it wait
Watch it get copyrighted watch my song cover get copyrighted and wait wait it might
No, I don't think it will wait hold on
It says restrictions none
Cartoon Network Adventure Time
You
Beautiful
Do you remember Adventure Time of course I remember Adventure Time I
Loved Adventure Time Adventure Time was like my favorite is is it is still my favorite?
Anyways, today's gonna be a more
What's it called today's gonna be a more chill stream I apologize if you like it when I'm hyper
But I can't do it today
Oh
Yeah, name all of Jake's kids fuck Jake jr. Hon. I don't remember exactly how many had like six Jake jr. TV
Kim killed one
What's in there one called like Vanessa
Seven
You
Viola Viola, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Um, fuck
I don't remember the others
Hello, let me look up the others
Oh
What was the tall one called that one was Kim Kilwan
All right, his kids his kids background his kids where his kids family why isn't it show family?
I
Know Charlie I
Got all of them except Charlie. It's just Charlie Jake jr. Kim Kilwan TV and Viola
Okay, I didn't remember Viola that well. I said Vanessa, but still
Still still what do you think of the adventure time finale? I know a lot of people didn't like it
Um, are you talking about with a ice king and like I?
Forget I forget her name
Like his girlfriend or I guess his ex-girlfriend who then became like a fucking
Unearthly spiritual being
Mm-hmm
Are talking about Jake's kids. Yes. Yes
Yes, Patty wait, what's her name Patty?
It was a patty
Betty Betty Betty are talking about Betty and ice king that finale or are you talking about like?
Bubble gum and Marceline
Like when they kiss at the end I
Love that shit. Are you kidding me?
That was nice. I was waiting for that like the whole fucking show. I
Thought it was Patty lol. Sorry. It's okay. I
Think I accidentally added Jake's granddaughter. Wait, Jake has oh he does. Yeah, you're right
When were they died finale they didn't die
Which one you're talking about
I'm glad they let them do the kiss after all those years of tension exactly exactly there's so many years of tension those two
And it was already confirmed that they were exes before
Why is my mouth so laggy what the fuck
What the fuck am I lagging in real life and not realizing it
Hello
I feel so bad for a friend he could never get a woman to love him
Yeah, I don't know. I don't I don't particularly feel bad
Um
It was a great character other than that he doesn't really need he doesn't need a woman to love him
Oh
He got huntress reserved kind of in the end
I don't know did he cuz it shows him in the it shows him at the end like he lived in a van
Jake already died. He had a
He had a tattoo of Jake on his for forehead on his chest
I cast manual breathing
No, no manually breathing
He had if you like flame princess and the hunters yeah, he had flame princess for a while
He had like some sort of relationship
He kind of fucked up the flame princess one himself though, and then fucking sit up and bun took over
There we go now it's back
Remember watching the episodes where bubblegum had Marceline's old shirt still with her and my kids self immediately said dang
They gay as hell. Yeah, I like it
He's just like me for real
No
None of them stayed forever no, but that's okay
Nothing lasts forever depression sadness
I
Me open
Let me open them wizard 101 I
Love what what they did with ice kings character in that show he starts off so goofy and not serious
But then became like the most depressing character in the show
He does become the most depressing character, but I like him as a character. I have a crush on ice king
I'll be honest. I have a crush on ice king, but if I was Betty, I probably would have still left him
Sorry
It's true. I would have still left him even if I would even even even if I was Betty just because of their story
Fuck I forgot my password again
I
Okay, hold on
No
Okay, now I got it ice king or Simon that's the same person
That's the same person
If I got cooked by cinnamon bun, I'd give up on
Do you know the war behind cinnamon bun like cinnamon bun was stupid up until he went until the ice king into the ice kingdom
Because he was undercooked and then when he not ice king the fire kingdom or what's it called?
I think it was the flame flame kingdom
Because he was undercooked and that's why he was stupid
Having a lot of loves and all of them end with a heartbreak would tear a man apart
Finn went through so many more
Then went through so many more crazy things than just like
Breakups
That was definitely what tore him apart more I would say then a girl leaving him
Who is this cute witch? Where's Amy? I've replaced Amy today
I'm the mean Amy and I cast testicular torsion
Whoosh
You noted it down, what did I note down
Y'all remember the Hall of Egress stuff that would mess up me that wouldn't mess with me more than any breakup
It's Hall of Egress when he like
Got he was blind. He was like trapped in a maze for like days or something. I
Still get lich as it's on my tiktok
Yeah, he lost an arm his dad betrayed him his fucking sword
even his like grass sword became conscious and became him and then had a hoax the existential crisis a
Bunch of shit happened
Your password you noted it down your password. Oh, well, I
Forgot I noted it down, but I remembered it with my brain
Finn stuff with his dad and with friend was way more messed up than girl trouble. Yeah
Finn went through a lot of crazy shit
But it's a kid's show so you know
Let me change
Yeah, and Jake died too, unfortunately
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do that's the wrong thing
Hello, I
Don't want to catch
There we go
Jake died. Yeah, you didn't know that Jake died
Finn needs therapy now he's got his vault. He just puts everything in the vault just like me honestly, I do the same thing
Everything goes in the vault
It was truly an adventure time it was is my favorite show I still watch it a lot
No
That's one of the thing I like about the Steven Universe sequel it's literally just Steven has PTSD it now
Does he I never watch Steven Universe actually
If you like Fiona and cake show I
Feel like the Fiona and cake show had a whole lot of young adults loving the show because we all had jobs
We hid and we wish we could go on adventures. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. It was um
Relatable especially Fiona's like shitty ugly apartment
That's really messy it was relatable
That's how my apartment looked when I had a job that I hated
It was rough
I
Mean start the game
Now apparently I
Was notified that they had like free
Subscriptions through the weekend or some weekend I never logged in during that time
So
Pee-pee-pee I didn't get anything for free
Unfortunately
If your nose apartment still looked better than mine. Yeah, it was still aesthetically pleasing to it was messy, but it was still nice
Okay
Sorry, I know I'm burping a little more than usual or am I
A little louder than usual
We will fund your subscription
Thank you, thank you
You can still redeem some goodies on their side if you want some free pulls
Free pulls is this a gotcha game? What do you mean free pulls?
Why can't I?
Where am I going?
What wait what where's this leading me to?
What am I supposed to jump down? I can't
Is this someone's like oh
I have no friends in this game
How do I how do I get down get down there am I supposed to go from the other side
Wait, how do I get back up from here all the stairs the
Portal the
Portal
There's a portal
Which portal
They done gotcha fried wizard 101 they did I mean it was always like oh there we go
It was always really pay to play
You can get mounts and such from packs. Oh, that's where the gotcha stuff is okay
Okay
So this way wait, I feel like I just went backwards
Why does it say there's more space in between me and the it
Think I just went backward
backwards
Even in games the rich get richer
Unfortunately, oh fuck off damn it
Sometimes I walk straight into these bitches and they don't even see me and then sometimes I
Like stay as far away as possible from them and they still like fuck me up
Yeah, it did teleport me farther away
How rude
Wow so aggressive see how demure I am with my spells very cute see
Very respectful just a one-time hit I
Don't unnecessarily punch the shit out of you. That's my brother's job
The hitbox is good insane you gotta wait for the green light to walk
Wait, did she regain health what the fuck
I
Why do I have less health than her
Okay, sorry, thank you for the sub I forgot
Sometimes I just hear the noise and I'm like Pikmin sound
But then I realized wait, it's not just a Pikmin sound it's someone it's someone membership. It's a membership
Not a sub
Oh fuck I'm gonna die
You want to be punched okay square up
I'm squared I'm set and squared okay, I finished my sandwiches
Brat raid courtesy of she be wait, what's a brat raid? What does that mean?
What's the brat raid summer is over
What's the brat raid is that the song huh hi she be
Oh
Welcome oh we're the brats you guys wait harlots are the brats
Who's the brat in this situation
Huh
You mean is the brat
Okay, I'm back to oh to High Ledge is it this portal
Okay
This is obviously not the portal what is even the point of this
How do how does one get down there your brat regardless I am
What which portal which portal how does
I
Feel like I feel like I'm going the wrong direction. I
Feel like there's a different direction. It's the portal near near the yellow arrow
Portal near that yeah, yeah, yeah, where's the yellow?
You wait past the portal
Okay, I'm gonna go back to where I was before
No
Walk across the bridge
You hold on I gotta deal with this thing first
The yellow arrow should work, but it I can't
Who the fuck is this motherfucker get out of my fight?
Who are you I invite you
Did it did the duel would you want to watch me play Yu-Gi-Oh? I don't actually know how to play Yu-Gi-Oh
Oops, sorry game post
There's two of them now
Whatever
Is Yu-Gi-Oh complicated
Is Yu-Gi-Oh hard we can always teach you do you know how to play it?
Modern Yu-Gi-Oh is pretty complex. Yeah, I heard maybe hi
Nice well fizzled. Oh shit, where do I get more mana from do you know?
Because I don't
Would you read the card effects no I would choose whichever card looks the coolest
Okay, let's let's kill this one and leave. Oh, then Yu-Gi-Oh is not for you
If you emulate an older Yu-Gi-Oh game, it could be fun. Mm-hmm. I don't think I care enough to emulate one though
I'm not great at emulating the only game. I've ever cared enough to emulate was diabolic lovers
That's my toxic trait
In pal what I want to play alone though
Do not join the game do not join. Thank you
Diabolic lovers interesting. That's my toxic trait. It's a terrible terrible terrible game
Like 15 steps back for for you got lost how to show the way
Wow these spells are so much cooler than mine what the fuck I'll get there I'll get there
Stream sniped in wizard 101. Oh, I've seen everything. How did you guys even figure out where I was?
Reefling me too. Oh, thank you strongy. Okay, fine. Show me the way
I won't accept friend requests, but show me the way
Is it are you is it this one who is it is it both of you?
Okay, I'll follow this one
I
Let's go I didn't see any um
Any portal though. Oh
This is the portal. Oh, thank you. Okay. All right. I'm an idiot. I'm just an idiot. Okay. Thank you
Hi, strongy. Good job on the cover by the way. Thank you
Wait, where am I supposed to go from here? Oh up here. Thank you. It was hard
It was hard actually not that one wasn't too bad now
What I can see let's see what I can see
Just remember to follow the yellow arrow and you'll be good. Thank you if I'm right and I usually am
Whoever's enchanting these storm amulets also kidnapped Susie. They probably have Susie imprisoned close by I
Can use the link between the wand and Susie to find her and the link between the storm amulets and their maker to produce a vision
Here goes mouth. It's the guy whose mouth doesn't move. Yeah, he's the nerd
He's the nerds the nerds nerd nerds emoji
Nothing, whoever this is, they want to accept friend of course because she doesn't want to friends with us. That's all exactly
Exactly true. I'm sorry
I'm alone will at the middle across the river go talk to blad raven eye and get us a crystal
Get us a crystal
All right
Have you been training it sounded great. Oh no
Well, I sing alone in the shower and shit, but um
Like
I don't think my shower singing is is what I would call training. It sounds pretty bad
I don't even know I used to actually like put in effort with like, um
Like blowing through a straw like that breath breathing exercise
The undead stole all my crystals
And like doing um, like the up and down
Like vocal vocal warm-ups and stuff. I used to do that, but now I'm just like
I don't want to do it anymore. I'm tired and that's probably why I haven't really improved I say
My lightning rod won't work a scarlet screamer stole the primary coil
You could help get me up and running again gather up the folks and get my coil back from the scarlet screamers
And I'll get you a crystal
Um, I was talking about diabolical lovers diabolical lovers is a dating sim for the place
PlayStation I think
And it's just
It's just like I don't even know what to call it
It's um, wait, where am I supposed to oh I'm supposed to collect three cogs, right?
Collect cogs in Triton Avenue
It's like
Yeah, it's an ultimate game
Yeah, basically it's so bad. It's good like absolutely terrible for um
Women's rights 15 steps backwards
It's a really fucked up game and I um, I didn't have a playstation. Um, and
Most of the game is actually not even translated. It's a japanese game
So what I would do was there would be tumblr accounts. Yeah, it sets women back a hundred years probably more
but there would be tumblr accounts that
would um
Just translate the game to you line by line
And I would literally just read read the translations like I wouldn't even play the games because
I couldn't even find like a
like a
You know pirated emulator version for it. I only found it for like one of the games
I think it was for like the base main game, but there's like multiple games for it
And and I would just read the translations and that's that's how I would that's how I would like
I guess know the game
Because there isn't really um, I don't know did I collect that one already or oh, I already collected three. Okay
Um, such a problem's over. Yeah, there isn't really like
Recordings of the game. There's like nothing really because it's kind of a niche game. So
I would just goon to like shitty translations
And I'd be like fuck. Yeah, this is the best
But there's some really fucked up scenes in that let's just say that there's some really messed up scenes
honestly the whole anime and
They made two seasons of anime is is awful. It's brain rot
Absolutely awful defeat scarlet screamer. Oh, there she is scotted street screamer
I'm after you
Um
That's how you know, she's a real gooner. Yeah old tumbler was such a gold mine once. Oh wait, sorry
I'm gonna fight hold on. Okay. There we go
um
Once you
Weed through all the trash. There wasn't that much trash on old tumbler to me, but maybe because I was younger
I didn't realize
Like most adaptations of vn otamu's unfortunately. Yeah, there's not a lot of english versions
I would have paid I I still would pay good money
I
Fuck the thoughts I'm having right now. It's so down bad
Like um, you know how I don't really have like a central AC in my apartment
I was thinking like oh, maybe I should get like there's I actually found a real a really close apartment to me
like really close early like a
Five minute walk away from me that has central AC
But I was like fuck. I should really just pay my student loans first before I actually um
I'll have to defeat more than one
One out of three. Oh, okay. Um
Because you guys are actually
Really helping me pay my student loans. I don't even know how much I owe
We should log in together into my student loans account and see how much I owe. I actually don't know
But I was like fuck. I should really pay my student loans before I become irresponsible with money
shouldn't I
And just now I was like, you know what? I should just buy a playstation
Get my ass on ebay
And like find the japanese games
And find those little tumblr pages and use them to to play the games. Wait, I have like no mono left
New apartment funds. No, I can afford a new apartment. I'm just like I should probably pay my student loans first, you know
Um
That's probably like the smarter thing to do. Um, unfortunately
All my homies hate education loans me too America seems to hate dating seems in general even if they're good
The diabolic lovers doesn't sound like it's all that good
Diabolic lovers would get canceled in America. They wouldn't even let that be on the market. They'd be like this is um
This is immoral
What do I do?
I don't have mana
I tried making her spicy cheesy ricey posted on twitter for dinner. It was great. Thank you for the inspiration. Ah, I'm glad you like it
It would I don't think I should play that on brimsley. Oh my god. Thank you for the
Okay, wait, genuinely. I don't have mana
What do I do thank you for the 50, uh
The the 50 memberships holy crap
Um, honestly from what I heard the faster you pay for those loans the less they'll cost you the longer until they go
Up with time. Yeah
What do I do flea?
I have to flee
Uh, what was that wait couldn't I have just pressed that button?
Uh
There's bad stuff on steam look like to wait what
There's bad stuff on steam too like sayano uta and no one bats an eye
I guess so you're right. You're right. Um
What do I
Um
The last time I heard of diabolic lovers was when the anime dropped and it seems like twilight but reverse harem
It's worse than twilight
It's like it's like 10 times worse than twilight. You can go to the school and get your free cards the school
Um, yes the school
The school
Uh
Rory wait, can I get more? Thank you for becoming a member
Um, did you play you me and her? No
Freak school i'm not going to school
Into ravenwood for free cards. Oh, this is the school ravenwood is like
Is it that way? Oh, this is raven. Thank you for helping whose birthday is it?
Wait, is someone talking to me in chat? I didn't see that
If you want to walk a little faster, you can get a free mouth. Did you just fart because you just blew me away?
Click the home button and go outside is this the school
Is this school school vice school? Oh, oh, which school am I in?
It's
That bad wow it is bad
Is the generate balance
But there's no school of balance here
Special
I
Monomous tipped $50 freedom from debt. Oh, thank you for the $50. It's actually helping me. Yeah, wait
Balance is the guide for the tree. Oh
Instructor balance. Oh
Oh free give me scorpion
Yes
Oh, I have to be level eight to unlock the others. Okay, cool
Um, we found it means class. No, don't say that don't say that
I hope the hell is even main manics. I don't know special
Um, isn't sienna uta like a horror that seems like something americans would hate a lot less than like weird pirate
power dynamic romance schlock
Schlopp you mean
I don't know
But any I know if you had mentioned it to like a girl that's into anime she'll be like
Ew, what's wrong with me? What's wrong with you?
Ew, you know
Oh, thank you for the $20 debt funds. Thank you
You can spend those training points for cards from other schools. Oh really?
I can go to like all the schools
um
There's so much shit around here. Hold on
I can go go to the girl's dorm
The boy I want to go to the girl's dorm. Where's the girl's dorm?
Is this the girl's dorm? No, it's the school of life. Why doesn't the balanced school have a whole fucking?
Oh
That's so cool. Should I just go to all of them?
Click your house button at the bottom
I
Have a whole house
Oh, yeah, I forgot you can have a house in here. I have a bank with money in it. Oh no, there's no money in it
Rip to your points. Oh shit wait, I didn't know I had a limited amount of points
If you're gonna play alone, I recommend getting some life spells to heal you
I
You can buy your points back, but
Or the spells that I got bad how do I get rid of this?
I
Panty raid this isn't the girl's dorm though, is it?
Oh, you bought life spells so you're fine. Oh
Oops, where am I? Where's my house on this map?
You
Unintentionally got a good school. It's just the healing school. Okay
I don't really seem to have many drawers in here for you to raid
The windows got like nothing in it. I live on those streets
Okay, um
So wait, where is my points?
Oh training points, oh
Oh
Can I get more like
This like mana or something
You are in the girl's dorm the tower on the right slot of the entrance slash exit of Ravenwood
Oh this tower
Oh
Oh, it's my house. Oh, there's no other girls though
The blue orbs floating around refill mana. Oh
Okay, I'm guessing I can't take that
What is this goofy? What do you mean goofy?
Okay, well, uh, let's go back to where we were before then can I teleport there?
I'm acting as if I know where I'm supposed to go
I'm so tempted to buy a playstation though. Oh my god, there's so much shit on screen
Just so I could play diabolic lovers again
There are some spicy scenes
There are some also just very immoral scenes
Most of the game was full of immoral scenes
But that's what I liked about it
That's what I liked about it. I spent like my entire summer of like
I want to say eighth grade summer
Is that from a while ago?
I think so
Because it's a super chat. Okay
Back to game sounds
You can leave a mark on the bottom right
Which will cost you mana, but you can teleport back to it from anytime bottom, right?
Oh mark location. Oh, okay. Thank you
Okay, okay, okay
Um, the immorality is what makes it spicy. Yes, exactly. You get it. Thank you. I'm glad you get it. I'm glad you get it
I mean, I guess I'm not what's in here
I don't know
I guess I'm not supposed to
I'm gonna close chat
Oh no, is that gonna say
I guess if anyone's gonna get it, it would be you
Thanks, we know a lot of these later. We're kind of spamming you with info. It's okay. It's okay. I don't mind
I
Dungeon you haven't unlocked yet. Oh
Okay, very cool. I like dungeons taboos are learning
Oops, sorry every time I click out of the game it makes it pause
Isn't spicy the point of those games? Honestly
Female like
Uh, I guess uh dating sims
Aimed for like a female audience are nowhere near
as like insane
messed up
fucked up as like
Dating sims aim towards a male wait
Wait
Am I going the right way?
Uh dating sims aim towards a male audience like especially like the popular ones
They're nowhere near as fucked up. Unfortunately. There's like a couple
That I can think of that are like
Oh, you play through the whole game and then like the ending is kind of messed up kind of
but
It's like you have to play through the whole game to even get there, you know
Our male dating sims fucked up. I think there's a lot more popular fucked up ones if you ask me
Omega verse stuff blows my mind. Oh my god. I literally got an omega verse tick tock ad
Wait, I was trying to advertise. I think it was trying to advertise someone's book or someone's app. It was so funny
It was like pov
You're no mega and you're in heat and your alphas
plural
Are away and so you have to satisfy yourself
So you fucking it was so random. Um, it was like so you sit on a knotted
um
build-o
I don't remember what happened. It was like you fell asleep on the knotted build-o and your alphas find you
And they're like we'll take it if you baby care
It was really cringey and so funny
Female oriented dating sims are wack but male dating sims are way more horny. Yeah
No, the female oriented ones are not that wack if you ask me. I mean, I'm sure they're cringe
But I feel like they're not that wack and they're definitely not as horny either. Yeah
Like if you want the fucked up ones you have to go for like indie ones
And even then they're not not that fucked up
What is her feet? My feet is surprisingly normal
My feet is normal actually
Like genuinely
How the fuck didn't I like that be allowed on a tiktok of all platformers
I go though, but it was funny as hell. Let them slip the giggle sticks
How do you fall asleep like that? I I I don't know
I
I I don't know ask she be she has a knotted build-o
I don't think we can match your freak on this one. I'm not I'm actually not really that into omega verse stuff
I think it's overused. It's cringe and overused
full of reckons
No, my tiktok for you pages not full of reckons
It is not that's just twitter and I don't know why I genuinely don't know why
Because my usual for you page is like my little pony like on twitter. It's like my little pony and um
Uh
Rats
Those two
But for some reason on imi
It was
Wait, there's nothing to it. Okay, bother this soggy place and be bother you if this coil
So precious to you take it. Thank you. I will take it
Thank you
Raccoons are the ponies of rats what
I don't have anything against raccoons. I'm just a little confused as to why my twitter like
Home page was just full of raccoon stuff on the on the one time that I scroll through it. Can I go in here? No
The one time I scroll through it
Stranny got another one. Oh, maybe I should get one too just to join in
Um
Be bother what does be bother even mean now put those cogs to good use and get the old wheel turn in
I'll fix the lightning rod
Okay
Which wheels these ones
Oh, there's fish in here. Oh my god, and they run away from you
Oh my god, they're so cute. All right. We're ready here. Just pull this lever and we'll charge that lumina crystal right up
Click the pet icon next to your mono
Yes, should I make my pet happier?
Well done wizard. Well done wizard
There's so many bronies that it must feel weird to be a female my little pony fan, huh? No
No, not at all. I I don't interact with the um
Thanks to you. I'm back in business. I don't interact with the pony fandom really
Other than like on twitter one brand new fully charged lumina crystal. She's a beauty. I hope she serves you well
Lumina crystal
Did he start laughing at me?
You laughing
Um, like I don't go to like pony conventions or anything
But you're right if I did there probably would be a lot of dudes there wouldn't there
Yeah, I just watch this I just watch the fandom from a chair
That's what I do. Yep
I don't I really don't interact with any of the fandoms I'm in
A lumina crystal this should be just what we need
The lumina crystal will boost the power of my ritual. It'll work this time. I'm sure of it
It's not work before. Oh, okay. It's working Susie. I can see her. But what was that horrifying thing with her?
That's the harvest lord. We studied him in class. He's a power
Underworld who harvest the souls of the innocent
Um, do those even still exist after gen four? I don't know
They kind of fucking look like she's in the fandom
I'll not kill them, but they slap the fandom across the face with the new system with the newest ponies. Honestly, they're so
They're so bad
I could go on a little rant about them
Because I watched I didn't watch the show
I'll go on a little rant about gen is a gen five
Is it gen five? I think it's gen five
um
I didn't watch like
gen three two or one. I um
Like I have my little pony toys, but I didn't watch the show
Mostly because I didn't know there was a show when I was a kid
I don't think I could even have the facilities to watch the show if even if I knew but
Um, I did watch like the the friendship is magic one
And I really enjoyed it. I really liked it. It was nice. I did watch a few of like
I think it was gen three. I watched the movies like the old movies
Um, one thing I didn't like about gen four is that they changed spikes spikes voice
When I first saw the new spike, I was like, who the fuck is this guy? This isn't a spike
This sounds nothing like spike
But then I got used to to spikes new voice and it doesn't bother me as much but they changed his voice
The old stuff is stereotypically girly it is but I would say the new stuff is too
If you wait if you've only watched in four wise material favorite because I watched the movies like the old movies
As well
That's why like I didn't watch the show, but I watched some of the movies
So
This is how we attract drama by talking about my little pony
Is that how gen five that bad I didn't watch okay, I'll I'll I'll tell you basically
Basically, um
Oh
Everything that they built up plot wise in gen four was like
Shad on by the new show and by the movie
Like the movie literally starts off by like telling the story
Of like the main six and being like look at all the cool things they did and they brought friendship to
To equestria and
And then they were like anyways, that doesn't apply anymore
Everything that happened. Yeah, we're gonna forget about that and um
We're just gonna poke a bunch of plot holes into the story and tell a new story that
Has absolutely no link and um contradicts the old story like no link to the old story and contradicts the old story
basically like um
Like the start of the movie for gen five
Is basically saying like back in the day
All of the all the pony types were friends
But now they're not anymore
and it's like
what happened
and also
In friendship is magic, you know, that was a thing where like the ponies weren't friends anymore like the the earthpony the um
the earthpony is the
What's it called pegasus is is and the um
The unicorns the pegasi and the unicorns
Um, that was a thing like they told the story of of how, you know, they weren't all friends at the start
And when that was happening they had wendigos
They had like the wendigos
going around and um
like
um
Massacring, I don't know causing trouble like it was all like a cold land and
Wait, what is this?
I don't know
Gen five gave magic to those who didn't have homes. What's with that?
Oh horns that too. So that too. That's another thing. So um, there was no wendigoons. Wendigoons. Wendigos
There was no wendigos
I knew my little prisoner would draw more to me like flies to honey
There were no wendigos in gen five. They were just like, yeah, none of the ponies are friends anymore
But forget about the wendigos. That's another thing that doesn't happen anymore. I guess um
And then not only that but um
Just instead of wendigos all the
All of the ponies lost magic and for some reason the pegasi just can't fly anymore
Because apparently you need magic to fly
That's something I didn't understand
Like oh well the ponies magic doesn't exist anymore
You know, they didn't know it's because the ponies weren't friends anymore
But they were just like magic existed long ago but not anymore
And also the pegasi can't fly and it's like but they have wings you don't need magic to fly
But then when they get their magic back they can fly but that doesn't make sense because you don't need magic to fly
Their wings aren't big enough for their bodies to fly so they have
So without magic, but it's stupid though. That was never like you don't need magic to fly. That's stupid to me
um and yeah, uh before in friendship is magic like
Only the pegasi had
Magical powers
Um, sorry not the pegasi the unicorns like only the unicorns had magical powers
The ponies with corn with horns had magical powers and that's it
Okay, if a pony had a horn, she had magical powers
But if she didn't have a horn, there was no magical powers at all, but for some reason
And also the ponies with horns and wings were like princesses, you know
Alicorns were princesses
But for some fuck ass reason they just made the main character like at the end of the movie
They gave her magic and they like made her an alicorn
And I was like, but why though? She's not a princess
Like why would you do that?
Then not needing magic was never part of the established lore. I think
Yeah
Wait
What
Their wings
Birds have magic confirmed. That's how birds fly. They're magical
I didn't know my little pony had so much story and lore to it. There's so much
I'm gen 4 everything in nature kind of needed ponies to interfere like leaves don't fall seasons don't change and weather doesn't happen really
Oh wait, no. Yeah, you're right. Yeah, you're right. Sorry. I forgot. Yeah
Yeah, they need the ponies to do it
Like bring the winter clouds over and stuff. I thought that was cool though
Yeah, sorry the pegasi kind of had weather based magic, but like not really that much
um
But another thing that fucked me up was fucking
In the new show first of all, I I I wanted to try watching the new show
Um Eliza Koshy voices one of the characters and I fucking hate Eliza Koshy. She's so fucking annoying
So that was one one of the reasons why I didn't want to watch it because I was like
I don't want to listen to Eliza Koshy all the time. She's zip and it's like shut the fuck up
The sound of her voice annoys me. She's just a youtuber if you see her stuff. She's like really annoying. I
She just annoys me. Okay her existence annoys me. So I was like getting annoyed by that
Um
Oh my god, the voice acting in this is so good. I know what he's talking about. Meet me outside wizard. I need your help
Okay
Um
Another reason is
Dude, so the graphics
Graphics, I guess the animation quality for
The movie was all right
It was it was not bad, but the animation quality for the show for gen five
Is so bad. It's genuinely
It's genuinely so ugly
Like and like channel storm energy. I don't even know how to explain like the harvest
I know it's goofy to enchant the ambulance girl. Your lipstick is awful
It's the old one was so popular. Why do they change generations? I don't know about my little pony. I don't know
They wanted to tell a new story. I guess what they fucked up
Do they have a poppers budget? Yeah powerpoint quality
It was bad. It was bad. It was really bad quality
And that's another reason why I couldn't watch it, but apparently they reintroduced spike
Which I thought was cool because there's no
Characters that actually show up from the old shows
Like literally none of them ever
From what I know
I think there's no characters, but they reintroduced spike for some reason
And at the end of friendship is magic
They show spike as an adult like spike was a child throughout the whole show
But they they show spike as an adult at the end and he's a Chad. Okay. He looks like a Chad
Not even the princess is not that I know of no, not even the princess is he was he wasn't mega Chad. Okay
He looked a little goofy and I thought it was funny because I'm not used to seeing spike like that because
spike was like a child throughout literally all like ever since spike was introduced
He was like a cute tiny little dragon. So it was super weird to see him chatified, but whatever
um
but
When they show him again in gen five, he's like
Suddenly an entirely different shape and body type
Like now he's like before at the end of gen four. He was like
standing on two legs
And then now he's like standing on four legs and he's like a long dragon
It was weird. He they DJ. Yeah, they de-chatified my boy spike
He's no longer Chad. What the fuck man?
They took his aura. Did he stop simping for rarity? Um, I don't think he ever stopped simping for rarity
But she's probably dead in the new show. So yeah
Look how they massacred my boy. That's genuinely how I feel about spike
and not only that
Um in gen four like every single what is this?
Oh, okay, can I do something with it?
Uh
I guess not the agent. Oh, okay recipe. I have no recipes
Um
In in gen four all of the dragons look different
Like they all have different body shapes and they're all different sizes
I think I have to use the teleporter
Like they all oh, there's another one over here
They all look very very different from each other
But then in gen five like all of the dragons just have the same body type
literally all of them and it's like
what
You you massacred the entire species at that point. Uh, did I fuck up?
Gen five spike looks like a background dragon inspired where sucks because the dragon design in gen four were so good. Yeah
It does look like a background character. It was the other one. Oh
Same body type sounds lazy as fuck. I know it's like they didn't want to um
Um
It's like they didn't want to make new 3d models for the new characters, you know
It's probably not like
Well
Oh, sorry, I didn't want to take a break. It's probably
That the nexus could explode at any moment the controls
They aren't working. I can't set it right. It's cheaper. It is cheaper
And you can tell that they're trying to make it cheaper because the show looks so cheap
It's so cheap
I'm really sad about that. I'm really sad about that
You can get to ravenwood and back quickly by pressing the mark button to set your location. Give it a try
Use the return to commons button to get back to the commons and then head to ravenwood
That sounds like a huge change between season four and five. Did they change directors or something? I don't know probably
Probably you know what I'm I want to I'm looking up this fuck-ass director
And you know what I'm setting a curses way later on today
My little funny
So the director for friendship is magic
Jason thyssen jason theason and jim miller. Okay, those were the two directors
But for gen five
It's
Fucking robert cullen and hos louis ucha
both of you
both of you fucked up
And mark fadabin and cecile kramer and peter louis all of you bitches fucked up and you're gonna regret it
I'm gonna make you regret it. I'm gonna make you I'm gonna make you regret massacring my favorite shill
Some coolest block was broke was probably like this is only a kid's show kids would never notice if we if we reduced the quality a bit
I notice I saw it all
I noticed it all
Part of it might be because gen 14 didn't want to make more but hasbro wants to make more. That's very possible
That's very possible
And you know what I'm I'm betting I'm gonna bet all
Out of money that those new producers
And directors didn't even watch the original fucking show
Or they watched like season one
Or they watched like season one and they were like, okay
I think we get it and then they fucked off and made you know the rest of the show
Don't have that
Here take this master key ring it against the metal of the nexus three times and the feedback loop should end good luck and move quickly
If you marked your location click the recall button to return to your mark
Tell them sis. I'm a vtuber and you'll regret this
I looked up lysokoshi. I see what you mean. I was only able to stand her for five seconds. She's really annoying
I don't know much about mlp, but if this wants them to pay they will pay
I was enough they could have grown up watching it
The directors no nothing not not gen four. I don't think they grew up watching it
Um, let me set up the thing. Can I know whose birthday it is?
Whose birthday is it?
Okay, I marked the location
The new team was like my little what never heard of it
You want me to write a show about ponies? Okay, sure. Yeah, I bet
I can do that
Oh, it's the anniversary. Oh 16th birthday. Oh
That's so exciting. Happy birthday wizard 101
Can I get these?
Give them to me
Um, nothing turns me off more than youtubers with no history of voice acting is voice acting in a show
It almost never leads to a good performance. You know what?
For this one, I don't think her voice acting is oh, we already have full mana. I don't think her voice acting is particularly bad
But I just can't stand her
like
When I first heard her I was like something's wrong. Something's wrong
My brain could tell something was wrong and I didn't like it and then I realized it's because it's fucking Liza Koshy voicing her
And then I was like, okay
What the fuck is going on here?
Okay
Congratulations wizard 101 year old enough to get real in England. Oh my
YouTubers acting in games is horrible too. I just I I'm gonna be real. I I don't yeah, she gave me the ick. I just I don't want
I don't want youtubers in my stuff
unless it unless they've had like
I don't know how to explain it
I guess I just want them to have more experience before they go into big shows like my little pony
Like start off small, you know
And maybe she did but also it's Liza Koshy. So I don't really care because her she annoys me
She annoys me in general. So I don't really care
Big bro carrying around in me. Yep. Like there's um
There's a youtuber that voices in dungeon meshi and I think he does a good job. I forgot his name though
I'll be real if I forgot or his name
But I feel like a lot of youtubers kind of just get in because of their names
Because they got that big name attached to them prosy deep prosy deep. Yeah. I watched his uh vines too. He was funny
MLP is starting small
MLP is not starting small excuse if I have the opportunity
to voice act
And my little pony I would be over the moon. I would be like holy shit
This is it for me. This is my big break. MLP is not starting small at all. Where am I going?
I
Me should voice everyone in MLP, you know what I'm gonna do my own horn. I feel like
I feel like I did a really good job singing um
Gypsy bard in our karaoke stream
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Oh here. I feel like I did a really good
Oh here
I feel like I did a really good job singing that song
I feel like my voice fit in that song really well and I think I could I think I could voice acted my little pony
But I obviously have not enough experience experience and my microphone is like nowhere near like studio
quality
Your voice works well for ponies. Yeah, I think it does
I think it does. I think I could totally be like some random background pony
Yeah, my microphone is nowhere near as good and also they're not recording the show anymore
So it doesn't matter. I was way too young when they were actually recording the show
Official cover when you're tempting me, but I
like
As fun as song covers are to me
um
They just don't they don't they don't do well, you know, so I'm not like tempted to make song covers
Uh, unfortunately
As fun as they are to do like
I think I'm better. I'm better off using the time to make like can you please direct me in the same fucking direction?
Why do you keep? I don't know. Maybe it's this way
Um, I forgot I was gonna say
Whoa, look at that guy
Oh, yeah, my time is better off spent like recording shorts
uh recording video like asmr videos, um
Recording honestly patreon audios. I still haven't done that for next month
So
It would be a love letter for us of my little pony song cover
Hearing you yelling and cussing mommy long legs from puffy playtime chapter two and honestly
I can imagine that in some chaotic scene in my little pony
Screw the numbers we love your passion projects, but
I care about the numbers
I'm a number idiot
I care about the numbers. I'm sorry
I care
Kira buckland technically started out small and online as well
And now she's a pretty big voice actor. I don't know. Maybe you'll see me in something
Down the line. Maybe who knows who knows probably not
I don't know
You rescued susie
Should I voice act the harvest lord has been driven back into the shadows should I voice actor wizard 101? That'd be so fun
I'm gonna send an email to wizard 101 with my demo reel. I don't even have a demo reel
I don't even have a demo reel, but um, that'd be so cool. So the harvest lord said he had a dark mass
Count you care about memories? I do
Even aside from projects we're here for you
I'm a pinpell because I find you children pleasant even in azatsu. Oh, thank you
Well, this is the numbers Andy. I am
Um, yeah, it's part of the job. I feel like if I didn't care enough about numbers like why am I even here?
Just at least a little bit you got to care, you know
At least a little bit. Otherwise, I should just you know
go back to like streaming once a week as an indy
and uh dicking around
Are they even creating new wizards 101 story for people to voice acting? I don't know
I don't know but from the sound of it. They don't have the highest um
They don't have the highest standards for their voice acting which makes me feel like I could get in
It makes me feel like I I could I could get in I could totally let me just send a quick email. Let me just uh
I have no strings to pull. Let me just beg on my knees and cry and plead
Isn't wizard 101 still updating?
They should be no, I don't know
Don't a thumb goal should have should have a MLP song covering could you know what sure sure
For for don't a thong sure. I'm fine with that
Are these side quests?
Just because that's a little different
Okay
Did you collect my fucking sticks before I could?
That's a little different because that's what you guys want. Um
Oh
What greetings young wizard?
So you're interested in learning about crafting
Wonderful
Let's get started with your first lesson
The first rule is to have a clean well lit place to work
Maybe maybe maybe we need to make a new demo table. I could yeah, I'd probably have to
She sounds just like
Other supplies
We'll need some mistwood
You can find mistwood growing all over wizard city. I think I have mistwood, right?
Bring the mistwood back I have and we'll soon have you a nice new place to work
I have mistwood though
Do you have the mistwood for me yet?
We're not we'll need it to build your basic crafting table hurry now
I thought I had it I was behind her
That mistwood should do nicely
Why she got purple lipstick? I don't know this game
She gets to work with hammer plane and saw in a few moments you have a nice little work table
Oh my I never heard her voice before they have a weird obsession with um
Weird cut weird colored lipstick in this game now with a basic crafting table you have a place to work
Thank you
Now with your work table you can begin to learn the fine trade of crafting
Her face reminds me of a titan from attack on titan
Did her voice change first?
It's just another narrator I guess
Crafting table in your dorm room or castle
Your first assignment is to make two daggers of absolution
You should have no difficulty
You'll need to buy a recipe from me and then gather the required ingredients
When you've got all your ingredients use your basic crafting table to make the athames
When you have made two daggers of absolution
Bring them back to me and I'll award you a novice crafter badge
A novice crafter badge
Good luck. I can't wait to see them. It's the goth lipstick which fists the sorcery theme
I guess I don't I don't particularly like the crazy lipsticks in this game though
I kind of have to ps
Have to go home
Did she just try to add a out of that was an old lady that was an old lady that is not out of out of
Yeah
Um, can I place the crafting table down?
The point of the stream we've all been waiting for crafting
A bit where is my crafting table?
Are those different clothes? Oh, no, that's just me
Oh the pissing break. Oh
This is not modern runescape does this game look modern to you
I'm never planning to runescape though
Wait, I can change my clothes. Where did I get these?
Oh god, they're so ugly
I didn't know I could change my clothes. Well, which one is better?
Oh god, they're all ugly
Thank you for the seven dollars. We you know, we love our pissing screen
I didn't know you liked it that much
You don't have you don't even have to leave your chair. I don't have a piss bottle
Okay, wait, genuinely, where's my crafting table? Didn't she say to place it down?
Oh
Wait, why is the crafting station like a guy? Oh never mind. I guess it's not a guy
Wait, wait, are you telling me that this doesn't flip?
It doesn't flip
Can women have piss bottles? My pee goes like everywhere
Like it doesn't go on a straight line. It like it goes everywhere. Like it
It like trickles everywhere. They're tingles everywhere. It tingles
Yeah, I need like a bucket
Put it down then you can edit it. Oh, there we go
Move
Fuck
Okay
There
What is this one a little sandy? Oh, is this my pet? Can I put my pet on the bed?
No, all right, little sandy you're gonna protect the door
Okay, make sure no one no one comes in
Stab them with your little with your little thing. Okay if someone comes in
Okay
She wanted to me to make a dagger right
Can you lay on the bed and puff? I don't know how the song goes
Puff puff Kimochi. What's the sticky stuff on me?
I
Cover when I don't know if I should
When is my birthday isn't it in April one two three four five
Eight months
One two three four five six seven eight eight nine you got like nine or eight months left
A certain orca and dvTuber gave ultimate TMI suggestion girls could aim with the right technique
Really?
I gotta hit her up and ask her for her technique
I gotta I gotta ask her for a video so she can show me her technique
Okay
Twitter exclusive. Oh you want me to just like sing it shittily with like my phone microphone on twitter?
Um, okay, I still don't know how to craft that dagger she wanted me to craft I need misty wood, right?
So
Dagger of absolution crafting station
Oh, I have to buy the fucking recipe are you kidding me? I don't even know
How do we get out of here? I don't know where she is
Dang it, okay. She's like really far away isn't she?
Yes, of course I ran out before I bought the recipe. I didn't know I was supposed to buy the recipe
Is she in the shopping district?
I don't know where this lady is
Do you feel this game is complex? Do you think kids would be able to beat this game? No
Kids are stupid and they can't beat this game. I can't even beat this game
I don't even know where I'm going
This is not the right direction. Wait, can I buy a new hat?
Hello
Lady buy it from me k bye
Is my game frozen?
Oh
Wait, wait a minute. You look familiar. Wait a minute. Wait a minute. I've seen that fuck it. I've seen your face
This is the same lady
This this is the same lady
She's just not black anymore
What
This is an ugly ugly hat. Oh, ew
Oh, can I like 400 dollars? How much money do I have or is this how much money I have and this cost 24?
Oh, that's kind of ugly
Oh, that's hella goofy
Oh
Isn't this the hat I started with though almost it's all the same person apparently
Yeah, I'm leaving. This is her buy racial twin
Okay, I'm gonna try to find that lady again and then we'll um
Oh
I'm lost
To my left
Is it old town
Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do
The random stuff you get from adventuring is better. Okay noted. Oh, thank you. Yes. This is the right way
And then you go through that door. You know what?
I remember when I was a kid cyclops lane was was pay walled
I swear it was pay walled when I was a kid. Did they
Did they um
No, not that door no walk down what oops
Did I go through the wrong
Old it's still free membership
It's still I know but when I swear wait, did I go the wrong direction?
Oh
It's still a free membership going on oh
Go down, huh?
Go back
Go down I'll go down to the left. Do you mean?
Okay, okay, okay
Trayton Avenue. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I mean I gotta walk all the way back to her. Okay. I'm gonna set a um a little teleport
Area there if I can unless I can only set one at a time
Okay, now I have to find this lady again. Um
Shit, I don't know where she was somewhere around here
So I should keep going this direction, right?
No
Go back
I can't see chat I closed chat
Press compass all that's helpful
Back to old town
What
How do I close this
Can't even find the next quest
Okay, I'm back at old town. Where is this lady?
Oh
Wait, is she right here? Oh, she's right here
I'm an idiot. Have you brought the two daggers of absolution? No shut up to make
If you don't have both of them, I can't help you, dearie. I don't want your help. Okay. I bought the daggers of absolution
I'm gonna mark this location
And then I want to go home
A big brother hand told to get me through the MML
Thank you
All right, make it do it sapphire
I don't have sapphire
Black hole
I need to fucking buy it from the lady
I need to buy it from the lady
Man this lady's making me jump through all these whoops
Oh
Lady
All the dude next to her
A reagent vendor, oh
That I need like multiple right?
It was just these two right
What is this thing around me her sense of direction left when she met the multiracial lady
No, I did it. I'm just always bad. Okay. There we go create
Wait, I need a two right
Oh fuck
I need to go back
No
It says no mark set I can only use it once
I didn't know I could only use it once
Literally walking so okay, I'm gonna get rid of all the
Compass stuff or no, I need the compass stuff actually
This is why
That's such a pretty mount. I want that mount
That happens to me when I meet biracial within his
Old town this way
All right, I'm just looking at the people in the game
When do you get mounts? I don't know
They need more they need new art for this game
I swear those same those same loading screens have been getting used forever
Okay, I don't like doing math. So I'm just gonna like just buy a bunch
There okay
Usually you get seven day mounts. Yeah, and that's annoying just give them to me forever
Fuck it
I'm done for today
I'm done for today. I'm gonna go pee and I'll be right back
So
Guys guys guys
Shebe's live on brosley, do you know what that means? I got I got it
I got a sneak in there. Hold on. Please tell me she's using a lovans. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Please. Shebe cotton bomb, please. Please
Please, please, please
She is
How do I how do I how do I how do I give it? How do I do it? How do I do it gift?
Uh
How do I do it? I don't know
Send
I don't know if it worked I hope it worked
I'm gonna wait until it says responding to blank and then I'll take a screenshot of that. It's responding to imi visu
I had to I had to you know pay her back the favor
Revenge
I
At least I don't actually I can't hear it. I don't know what she's saying. Let me just make sure you can't hear it either
Okay, let me try the one
She's so cute
Okay
Anyways, I'll I'll stick with you and chat until it starts responding to me
Did you touch your glasses to your eyeballs? I don't know why is it because it bounces
Mine's coming up next
Arf arf arf arf
Hold on. Let me let me take off the wizard thing
I want to a lot of times people come into chat while I'm like done playing the game and they'll be like
Why aren't you playing the game? So I feel like I need to like
Make a little text thingy that says like by the way we're we're done playing
We're done playing wizard
Just chatting now
There
It's almost October. I know it's so exciting
I um
How how hold on I where's my blanket?
I don't know. How long did you guys trick or treat for? I trick or treat until I was like
Yep, I trick or treat until I was 17
And I wanted to trick or treat until 18
but
I don't know
I should have
You're meant to stop eventually I guess unfortunately
And I really really wish that I I could give out candy. I would love
I would love so much to dress up and and and give out candy
Like she saw me. What did she say?
Wait she's
I
Um kids don't even trick or treat around here anymore. I know that's the thing like
Um
No, it was someone else's don't know but almost almost
I'm still here she be anyways, but don't talk about me in chat. Don't talk about me in chat. Don't don't talk about me in chat
She she she she she she shut up
She's spending quality time with her harlots. Okay, um
Uh
I forgot I forgot what I was gonna say um in my neighborhood um
Like
It's really it really depends on the neighborhood
One care more kids every time bro. It really really depends on the neighborhood
no shut up you're not here for a movie stream guys shut up shut up don't have to
show your fucking mouth shut because I will shut up don't mention me don't
mention me in a chat I will find you shut up anyways
man that bitch um yeah it really depends on the neighborhood like some
neighborhoods have a lot of kids and I feel like it's mostly like richer
neighborhoods where there's a lot of kids
uh trick-or-treat you know I feel like it's richer neighborhoods usually where a
lot of kids trick-or-treat but my neighborhood is like shitty like my
neighborhood is right in front of a really busy road so there's like no one
no one trick-or-treating here but I would just fucking I would just love to
dress up in like a cute little Halloween outfit and like give candy to kids and
scare kids I would love to scare the kids it would be so fun but I don't think
I'll ever own a house so I'll probably never never give out candy to kids even
my mom's neighborhood doesn't trick-or-treat you know rich people don't
even give out candy most of the time they thought they did yeah you got to go
to the suburbs like deeper into the suburbs which I never lived in the
suburbs really go sit in the park with a bag of candy
that's so fucking sauce it mean not only dishes out candy but also PTSD yeah I
don't think I'll ever own a house maybe like a condo or what's it called like
those like small houses that are like connected like multiple of them are
connected together like maybe one of those but even then I'm not sure you
know condo townhouse maybe maybe it's called a townhouse something like that
I live in a small town and even here there was only one kid last year holy
shit duplex not a duplex I feel like duplex is a more expensive I don't know
I bought a house earlier this year so doesn't feel real that's crazy RV owner
dude is it fucked up that I I would totally live in an RV but I feel okay
it would be kind of it would kind of be annoying though you know what I need to
that reminds me I need to buy a new buy vibration tool
buy vibration here do you want do you have any um the RV owner who can't drive
the RV oh yeah that's true massager it's true I can't drive Rick I have a I have
a short coming up about that actually I only just wrote the I only I only just
wrote the script where I haven't recorded it yet um what is this one oh oh
that's fun I need to buy a new Xbox controller yeah
house prices do be a pain let me just let me just
just this one let me get one more it feels so weird to like do this life there's
some crazy ones whoa what is oh wait is that one for dudes wait how does this
work oh it's for dudes never mind I think it's for dudes at least oh it says male
yeah never mind never mind the witch cackle how many are you get seven five
what do you mean I'm not getting five of them um
you know what this one never ended up working hold on should I test out hold on I'm gonna go
get a massager I'm gonna test if it works cuz I could I when I first got it I don't think it
worked but maybe let's test out the one I got before the bird is finally out what bird
the brands oh I'm just getting
L O L O V E N S E that's all because it's more fun when you guys control it on stream if you
ask me it's more fun what should I take off the vod premium version with all 24 points
what what what do you think I'm buying right now
I'm back I didn't think I just went to get the back massager that's all I want to get the back
massager because I I think the one I got is broken
so I mean I spent too long to yes it's a back massager yes it's a back massager
unless there's another button that I'm not pressing which is
like possible the back shot massager skibbity immy
let me check something hold on let me check the app no wait that's the wrong app this is
yes well no no no I'm not using it no no no no no I'm not an idiot
what kind of fucking idiot do you think I am I'm a little bit of an idiot but I'm not that much
an excuse me um yeah this one doesn't show up as available that's such a shame
the best kind of I mean idiot
okay I'll get a new one of this one I guess okay that one stream doesn't count
pretend that stream never fucking happened okay pretend that never fucking happened
okay okay female attachment wait what does that mean
I don't know what that means
we do a little bit of trolling strutty what two toys the other day in a member's ASMR
oh I'm doing it I I mean I'm not doing anything I don't know what you're talking about
well strutty's doing that wow that's crazy
I'm just gonna I'm like so um
I'm so scared that you can see my screen right now as I'm typing in my address
yeah we're just chatting we're just talking
okay
please tell me my PayPal works on this
sleigh
yay
okay I got some oops sorry I exited out of vtube studio just to check the email on my phone
okay I got hello oh no oh there we go I got some fun stuff
can you write off this purchase off on your taxes I probably could but I'm not smart enough
to do that to be honest
hi 55 goon out
oh let me take off the
the items
there we go
I'm just looking at back massagers and I'm done unless I should get a third one
should I should I should I get a third one I changed it in front of you yeah I know it's not
wait I just realized I put the tips on top of the model there we go isn't that crazy
I'm more than a barrier
okay fine I'll get Tanera as well I got what did I get I got Gemini and I got another
dummy too because the one I got before fucking is broken so let's get Tanera as well
why not
get a fourth one no no join the okay we're not talking about this on youtube
we're not we're not talking about this on youtube at least not unless it's a member stream
you know what I notice I look kind of weird without glasses now
okay
PayPal
okay great I hope it doesn't take like eons to arrive
I know people do look really different without the glasses now I feel like I look different
without the glasses should I put them back on do they have glasses on v2 studio that are like
normal glasses
no I think they only have sunglasses
so
is this what you want I feel like it looks goofy without the whole wizard outfit though I don't
like it
you
you look cute either way I'll leave it I'll leave it I'm glad you like it either way though
nobody's streaming
unless Azura is streaming Azura
I don't have her waiting rooms
I don't see her waiting rooms
until someone goes like that that could take so long
that could take so long I don't know absolutely not
but what I will do is I will go on twitter oh that's disgusting
she be through I can't read she be
I can't read she be
no we're not scrolling through twitter again I'm just going through my twitter following list
and um like
um following the the vtubers
that I haven't followed yet on youtube
you know what does this girl stream
oh she does perfect okay I'll follow her
you guys should go check out Rina Luxper I think I think her content would um
would pique your interest wink wink not that she's me I'm not saying she's me but like
you'll see
um helped she be finished her homework I helped she be finished her home really
I'm so happy
oh vivid I should follow the vivid girls
oh banana banana from vivid is is um live here we'll read banana banana banana I don't know
I'm so considerate considerate and helpful yeah
oh
oh Eva's streaming too I don't know forever I don't know if it's ever Eva
I'll do that Eva Eva Eva Eva
well says helping with homework usually opposite happens I'm just that good
I'm just that good yeah I'm just that good
it was your tutoring that helped her finish wink wink wink I can't even wink twice
there we go wink wink
I'm sorry I keep yawning because
it's not late but frog wink I can't even do it on purpose it happens by accident
I don't know I'm sorry for making you yawn I can't stop myself
you go rest I don't want to rest I want to stay longer
I want to stay longer
you know
I also just don't know what to do let me lean back into my chair what should I do
oh no the tracking is gone see this is what happens uh there we go did it yeah okay
just let us look at you
you want to scroll through Twitter again should we do some sort of meme meme review
do you want to play um
there's like games on there's like games on the windows store did you know that did you know that um
um there's games on the windows store and they're all bad
too short can't even lean back in the chair what I am leaning back in my chair right now
there's this one like really shitty um
um
hold on I'm checking TikTok there's this one really really shitty um windows game that's right I
played windows games um I forgot what it was called but I would play it um
I would play it during like final seasons when I got stressed it was called like
like
little village or something like that virtual village
do you does anyone remember like the virtual games like virtual family virtual village
I would get so obsessed with those games it's not mine sweeper I'm not fucking smart enough I
don't know how my mine sweeper works um you know the virtual virtual family virtual village
they're like a series of games on like the app store and luckily there's virtual village
sorry virtual villagers on the on the fucking uh windows microsoft store
and it's literally you just take care of like a virtual family or in this case a virtual village
bro my you can like level up your villages and stuff and make them bigger and make them smarter
I have so many like villagers die because if you leave for a long time um
if you leave for a really long time then your villagers will get like a fucking plague
just die and you'll come back to like two villagers and they're both like elderly
they're both like elders and they're all alone and then you come back and like your entire
cemetery is like full your entire cemetery is full of all your um
all the villagers okay wait hold on I kind of want to play webcams too how do I log into webcams
I want to play the old webcams
play webcams classic I hate games that try to make you feel bad for not playing
it's because they want you to like play consistently right that's why
how do I play webcams classic
oh here it is webcams classic
oh you need the application you guys will ever want to have a webkin stream
I don't know if we'll be able to do a whole webkin stream right now but I can
introduce you to my webkins if you want I think my webkin's names are really funny
they're really um
you'll see you'll see you'll see
games that make you dependent like a drug it's not a drug official villagers isn't a drug it's
it's just I don't know it was funny it was a funny game to me it was like the Sims I guess
kind of but like with a bunch of characters are you saying webcams or weapons I'm saying
webkins hold on let me let me sit up for webkins
okay um I need to log in
ah
fuck
the question is do I remember my username
shit
fuck I don't remember my username
how do I not remember my username
ah
ah I keep typing it wrong I typed that wrong for sure
should I go plug in my old laptop that has webkins download to it
she'd be raid she'd be raid wait what did she be like post a link to my stream
hello
welcome
well this pork wasn't there but I'll send the high five
welcome here again
I'm literally trying every combination from what I know because this is like
I want to say I was like less than in first grade this was like before first grade
that I still have the same account
should I text my mom like right now do you think she'll know
good job Amy you helped she be finished
I'm glad I could I'm glad I could help
forgot password parents email dude
as if I remember the fucking email call her on stream no because she's gonna answer with my real
name she's gonna be like hi Amy real name what's wrong no I can't do that
huh
mute
she's not she's gonna call me Timmy
the problem is I don't know if she knows either I remembered for a long time but I guess
unless they did they they recently delete in active accounts
did they recently delete in active accounts
no they're not gone I I I I um I log in once in a while I see them
the thing is she doesn't even remember her own password so the if she remembers
any like the fact if she remembers my webkin's password it would be like some sort of miracle
let me google it
what
when was this done
free accounts will be deleted after six month of inactivity paid accounts will be deleted
after 24 months of inactivity
what
from April 2nd 2019
I swear I've logged in after that
I swear I've logged in after that though
oh
man
am I learning right now on stream that all my fucking webkins are done are dead
so
I have so many
they're all dead
I keep trying but it's useless isn't it
uh
I'm genuinely super sad about this all my fucking webkins are dead
I swear I've logged in after 2019
webkins don't die if we have to delete an account from our archives because a player
has abandoned it we put those pits up like for adoption so they can find you
shut up they're dead oh they're dead they've been they've been sent to the gulag
come on
oh
that account information is not correct
I want to
I don't want to raise new ones I want my old webkins
I want my old webkins it's possible they emailed somebody but
you think I know the email that I used that email is from like
I don't want to say how many years ago but fucking I don't have access to whatever email
was used that email is if it even still exists which it probably doesn't
man I'm literally so sad right now all my weapons are gone
yes I'm sure I want to quit
you
do you think you would have tried to change the password to something else last time you logged in
I don't think so
email honestly should be around well if it is round I don't have access to it and I have no
way of getting access to it because my mom my mom most likely doesn't know it
you know my mom's not the type of like my mom's the type of mom to be like hey like to call me
and be like hey emmy why did you change my channel on the tv how do I change it back
like she doesn't know email passwords she doesn't know webkins passwords you know
she'll call me and be like emmy how do I how do I get to netflix on the tv emmy
emmy how do I get to the internet on the laptop how do I open the internet
something like that emmy did you change the google page
you wouldn't have written it down anywhere on your phone if I ever wrote it down anywhere it
would have been on a like a piece of paper in my diary when I was like seven I don't have that
I don't have that with me you know we're gathered here today to mourn the passing of emmy bees with
webkins well I could I could talk about my webkins I had a fox named folks f o x e I like that fox
I had a I had a um I had a frog named greeny
g r e e n i e I had um
I had um an ice dragon named sporkles
s b o r c k o l s
um
I think I even had I don't know
I had a bunch of a bunch of misspelled um
um
what's it called I had a bunch of misspelled webkins
and it was cute
okay well
um
oops wrong thing
I want to send you off to eva stream um enjoy
she's singing right now she has really pretty singing
oh my god she's she has very great singing um so I can't listen to it because I'll cry
but she has amazing singing so um go go enjoy her singing um I'm not gonna be okay I'm genuinely
so sad about my webkins being dead like I'm not gonna be okay I need to go cry in the shower
like genuinely I'm tearing up goodbye I'll see you on Wednesday love you
you